in the previous video we saw what a lan  is you know  a network which can span across a small  region now imagine  you want to connect devices across  multiple cities  or multiple continents now that's a huge  network and that kind of network is  called a van  in this to explain this let's take an  example of an office campus you can have  multiple buildings  you know multiple floors you have  multiple computers in this  different floors so how do you connect  them you take a router  and put it in each floor connect all the  computers in  in that floor to that particular router  and you take a bigger router and you  connect all of your routers to that  and that's how you can create a small  van